Facebook is cracking down on the spread
of false information in the final weeks
before the midterm elections the world's
largest social network says it will ban
fake content does not design to suppress
voter turnout comes two weeks after
Facebook says hackers compromised 29
million accounts and stole users
personal data
Tony the copal shows us how Facebook
says it's trying to protect the
democratic process Facebook protecting
the democratic process I still do double
take when I hear that scandals involving
this information and data misuse over
the past few months have forced Facebook
into all-out damage control this latest
policy change announced only yesterday
addresses one of Facebook's most
sensitive challenges how to define false
information and then remove it now this
is an important election year not only
the big us midterms that are coming up
and during major elections around the
world in may CEO Mark Zuckerberg pledged
to prevent election interference on
Facebook in 2016 we were slow to
identify Russian interference we didn't
expect these coordinated information
operations and large networks of fake
accounts that were now aware of to help
reduce the spread of disinformation
Facebook in 2016 began prohibiting
misrepresentations about the dates
locations times and qualifications for
casting a ballot on Monday the company
announced an extended policy to include
statements about whether a ballot will
be counted and misleading posts about
how to vote including false claims that
voters can cast their ballots using text
messaging that hoax circulated on social
media during the 2016 election with ads
instructing users to text their
candidates name to a five digit number
they've seen a pattern of a lot of false
statements about voting so they've
decided to take this extra step Facebook
has traditionally shied away from
banning misinformation says CBS News
contributor and wired editor-in-chief
Nick Thompson which is why this new
policy marks a significant step for the
company
the stakes are now high they said they
will delete false information but now
they have to define false information
and that's not easy the era of the Wild
West in social media is coming to an end
on Capitol Hill last month lawmakers
threatened greater scrutiny and even
regulation if Facebook and other social
networks failed to gain greater control
of their services I believe Congress is
going to have to act 2018 election is
gonna be a very important moment for
Facebook if they can get through the
midterms without people manipulating
American democracy through the platform
it will show that they took on the
problem and they handled it but if
there's another disaster if the election
gets manipulated through Facebook it's
gonna just deepen the problems they
already have now facebook says it uses
real people including third party fact
checkers to review content that is
flagged as potentially involving voter
suppression the company also says it set
up a dedicated reporting channel for
state election authorities to also
review content Facebook safeguarding
democracy we hope well then there's this
story on that's on the front page of the
New York Times day which is pretty
stunning to read if you care about what
happened in Myanmar and Burma and the
mass genocide religious genocide
essentially it was a propaganda machine
that was carried out by a number of the
senior Myanmar military leaders inciting
violence against Muslims there and as we
know what that led to there that was a
propaganda campaign how does this go
through without anybody noticing and
that it's happening it's a very fine
line you have a private company
entrusted with drawing a line between
free and open expression and what is
excluded speech and how to do that and
do we want them to be doing that that's
right and also try to adjudicate some of
these debates everybody people are gonna
think dude something you've taken out
because it's fake news is actually real
news which opens up a whole other
kitchen for two years ago Facebook
service wasn't a problem now they're
acknowledging it right Tony thanks so
much